monsieur Lacombe la bâtisse patrimoniale
qu'on a ici derrière nous et toujours en
flamme en fait on voit la fumée qui
s'échappe l'odeur qui trait présente
dans le secteur vous avez vu ça de près
ce qui s'est produit les conséquences de
cette incendie vos premières impression
d'abord j'ai envie de dire c'est une
tragédie bon tout d'abord bonne tragédie
humaine parce que heureusement pas de
blesser grave les pompiers tout va bien
puis les citoyens évidemment mais c'est
une tragédie quand on regarde un point
de vue de patrimoine et aussi je vois
envie de vous dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'on perd des logements c'est une
tragédie parce qu'on est dans un
contexte de crise du logement donc
évidemment de voir bâtiment magnifique
avec tant d'histoire qui avait tout été
rénové être la proie des flammes c'est
extrêmement troublant oui d'autant plus
que c'est je pars on parlait tantôt avec
la député Manon Massé qu'elle a député
du quartier ici qui a dit c'est un phare
pour les gens avec la coupole le clocher
donc oui le caractère évidemment
patrimonial je trouve que c'est décevant
1846 donc quand on parle de patrimoine
là c'est du vrai patrimoine puis
plusieurs raisons en plus de ça il y
avait une utilité aussi c'est un projet
où non seulement la communauté il y
avait une place c'est un lieu de
diffusion mais c'est aussi un lieu
d'habitation donc heureusement il y a
personne de blesser c'est sûr c'est une
bonne nouvelle mais en même temps c'est
vraiment une perte importante sur le
plat strictement patrimonial parlons un
peu plus de cette perte honnête placé
devant le fait accompli il faut déjà
commencer à penser à la suite non
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour garder cette
mémoire la préserver je sais qu'on est
au stade initial que vous voulez surtout
vous assurer que tout le monde est
correct ici mais quand même pas long de
la suite qu'est-ce qui peut être fait en
tant que ministre qu'est-ce que vous
avez en tête c'est sûr que tout peut
être fait ultime reconstruire
reconstruire Valérie disait tantôt avec
beaucoup de justesse que son était
capable de reconstruire Notre-Dame de
Paris on est capable de faire à peu près
tout mais en même temps c'est sûr que
pour l'instant on est encore à mesurer
l'étendue des dégâts donc je pense qu'il
faut être prudent mais il y a une
volonté de faire quelque chose de
redonner une valeur à tout ça de
préserver la valeur je pense que c'est
une évidence ne serait-ce que parce il
faut que ça continue d'être utile pour
la communauté puis parce que ça fait
partie du patrimoine malheureusement
pourra jamais faire recréer ce qui est
ce qui est disparu avec la fumée on peut
essayer de s'en rapprocher puis
évidemment il y a des fonds qui sont
disponibles moi je pense qu'on pourra
travailler avec avec la ville on peut
pas travailler ensemble absolument puis
je pense qu'il faut se rappeler aussi
que Montréal on est une ville
patrimoniale patrimoine de l'Unesco
aussi et donc c'est ce qui fait notre
c'est comme ça qu'on se démarque on dit
souvent l'Europe qui rencontre
l'Amérique Montréal partout en Amérique
du Nord on va à Toronto on a absolument
pas cet équivalent de patrimoine qui
fait la beauté des lieux qui fait notre
reconnaissance qui à l'international
alors il faut vraiment prendre soin et
c'est pour ça qu'évidemment quand on
aura une compréhension de l'étendue des
dégâts va pouvoir discuter de quoi ça va
ressembler la suite
il y a une protection autant à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur c'est sûr
que bon la force des choses fait que on
devra être flexible mais il y a une
protection donc des obligations aussi de
prendre soin de consensus là-dessus sur
la valeur patrimoniale à préserver c'est
pas le premier cas d'un élément
patrimonial qui malheureusement subit ce
genre de sort là il y a pas quelque
chose de plus à faire en amont on parle
de la préparation des pompiers qui ont
pas nécessairement la connaissance fine
de l'architecture de ce type de lieu-là
qui remplit difficile leur travail
est-ce qu'il y a pas une expertise à
développer aussi au chapitre en ce qui
concerne la Ville de Montréal j'ai envie
de vous dire que les pompiers pompiers
du Service des incendies de la Ville de
Montréal sont extrêmement compétents
formés
parce que c'est il travaille ici et puis
depuis hier soir exactement et en fait
faut savoir que les bâtiments
patrimoniaux c'est quand entre eux il y
a des rénovations qui sont faits dans
les règles de l'art selon les permis et
tout ça mais c'est souvent quand les
bâtiments il y a différentes du plus
récent avec du plus vieux mais il y a un
code du bâtiment qui existe au sein du
gouvernement du Québec évidemment les
pompiers suivent les règles suivent des
formations est-ce qu'on peut en faire
plus moi je pense que toujours matière
mais je veux quand même assurer la
population qui si un les rénovations
étaient faits dans les règles et bien
sûr les pompiers suivent la formation
nécessaire mais encore une fois quand il
y a beaucoup de fumées quand c'est dans
un autre toit parce que le chef des
incendies expliquait entre toi là entre
deux doigts c'est extrêmement déjà
intervenir et pense que c'est en tôle et
ne pouvait pas percer alors il y a aussi
un enjeu technique lié à cette incendie
il y a la formation des pompiers
effectivement Valérie viennent en parler
mais il y a aussi l'entretien des
bâtiments ça je pense que c'est il y a
des lacunes aussi des lacunes je dois
dire que dans ce cas-ci il y avait une
visite UE cet été il y a des
autorisations de travaux qui avaient
déjà été donnés donc un bon suivi
l'important c'est de continuer puis oui
de travailler avec les services de
sécurité incendie mais je pense qu'on
est on est bien parti le ça va bien en
matière de patrimoine très bien merci
poursuivons sur cette voie merci
beaucoup merci